[Music]
what would goofy look like as a regular
dude what about Donald and Daisy Duck if
you have a favorite Disney animal
sidekick
chances are it's on this list stay tuned
to the end to see a certain snow-covered
pal reimagined as a cute human guy new
here subscribe to the things channel to
be the first to see our new videos and
hit that thumbs up button if you like
this video if you like crafts and DIYs
check out our friends at crafty hackers
they have this awesome video about ways
you can recycle regular objects into
toys they'll show you how to turn your
useless everyday items into amazing kits
toys make sure you check them out and be
sure to leave them a like click in the
corner to watch now here are 20 Disney
animal characters reimagined as people
Mickey and Minnie Mouse when talking
about the famous animal characters of
Disney it seems only appropriate to show
the most famous Disney Mouse of all
after all he's been there since the
beginning and has stood the test of time
everyone at the Disney theme parks loves
wearing those iconic ears on their heads
and just like Mickey Minnie Mouse has a
special place in our hearts too that's
why the artist who goes by the name of
Sakura Joker on tumblr reimagined our
two favorite Disney characters as humans
in this adorable interpretation our
favorite part of this drawing is how
their hair still looks like Mouse ears
how cute is that Simba Pumbaa and Timon
have you ever watched the Lion King and
wondered what the characters would look
like if they were people instead of
animals well if you have you're not
alone Japanese animation artist Chico
who also goes by the name of choco on
deviantART com did this spectacular
drawing of Simba Pumbaa and Timon
strolling through the jungle singing
Hakuna Matata we are in love with the
way the artists captured the animal
qualities of each character while making
them undeniably human Pumbaa still has
that warthog posture Timon stances very
meerkat like and Simba's red hair is
very reminiscent of that kingly lion's
mane this is one talented artist
Zootopia a bunch of artists on the
internet have the same idea there is a
ton of artwork out there depicting the
animal characters from Zootopia as
humans our favorite is this anime style
one of Nick wild and judy hopps by
Mongoose 369 well actually it's a tie
between this one and the side-by-side
art of our two favorite Zootopia
characters created by emelina she really
captures Nick's aloofness
and Judy's zest for life Judy even has
the bunny teeth smile and we are amazed
at her ability to turn a fox into a
human seriously that's some next-level
stuff right there Nick and Judy never
looked so awesome Lady and the [ __ ]
so apparently lady in the [ __ ] is
loosely based on Walt Disney and his
wife's real-life cocker spaniel how many
dogs have had major motion pictures made
about them that's one special dog anyway
one artist wondered what lady in the
[ __ ] would look like if they were human
instead of dogs the results are pretty
doggone terrific the artist who goes by
pug Leto on tumblr really captures the
sly street-smart [ __ ] and lady's wide
eyed fascination with her new friend you
can see her inner monologue saying he's
a [ __ ] but I love him her hair looks a
lot like cocker spaniel ears and [ __ ]
scraggly hair under a hat is a perfect
choice scar we would be remiss if we
didn't include scar from The Lion King
along with Simba Timon and Pumbaa this
artists from deviantART Lloyd Kessler
really nailed this human version of scar
he's got long fingernails like lion
claws and he's actually kind of hot can
we say that about a Disney Lion villain
we are loving the hair and the goatee
even the scar on his eye looks cool yeah
we know scar nearly destroyed Pride Rock
and tried to overthrow the kingdom but
yowza that Mouse doesn't look too happy
though just remember what Zazu said scar
don't play with your food an artist
horsing around this artist who goes by
Sol Lena wrote that they have often
wondered what Disney animals would look
like if they were human the artist said
they have enjoyed other artists
illustrations of cartoon animals
depicted as humans and
- try it - so here is the artist's
interpretation of Samson Pegasus
frou-frou and Khan if they were human
the artist just chose a few of their
favorite horses and plans to do more the
artist wrote that they are still
laughing about how frou-frou is
virtually the only female Disney Horse
good point Selena why are all the horses
male Finding Nemo here's an interesting
question what would the entire cast of
Finding Nemo look like if they were all
human we found the answer and it's all
in one incredible drawing check it out
artist miss Canaan did this remarkable
version of all the Finding Nemo cast as
anime style human characters and to
quote crush the turtle it's awesome it's
even got the sharks Marlin and dory are
in action right in the center and crush
and squirt are there too
Nemo is so cute we love the extra
details of the scuba mask in the Sydney
Opera House miss Kanan is crushing it
with this one get it
crushing it okay moving on Daisy and
Donald Duck the deviant-art artist choco
also known as Chico has done it again
with this romantic drawing of Daisy and
Donald Duck as humans the two lovebirds
are dressed in gorgeous old-timey
clothes and they are locked in a tight
embrace this must be one of the times
they weren't fighting these two have got
some crazy tempers we love the duck tail
in the back of Daisy's hairdo and the
way Donald is looking into her eyes
looking at this picture makes us believe
in the power of duck love but does
anyone else think Donald's hat looks
like a big slice of cake okay now we're
hungry Nala is it obvious that we are
obsessed with the Lion King luckily were
not alone several artists felt compelled
to turn our favorite jungle characters
into humans when we found Nala we knew
we had to share it she looks like a
goddess and we cannot get over it
Zillah looks pretty awesome in this one
too you may recognize this style by the
artist Selena who did the horse drawings
from before Disney should give this
talented artist a call they should use
these incredible talents in their next
picture we would definitely buy tickets
to that movie what do you guys think of
this verse
Nalla flounder you guys remember Ariel's
sidekick flounder from The Little
Mermaid right he's the cute lovable blue
and yellow fish that helps Ariel in her
under the sea adventures but what would
he look like if he was a boy instead of
a fish one artist called the ninja 293
drew a pretty cute version of flounder
as a boy the artist said it was fun and
that they hadn't drawn a boy in a long
time we think we can speak for almost
everyone when we say we are so glad they
did
look at those blushing cheeks and blue
eyes the hair looks like a fin on top
nice touch
Mike and Sulley do monsters count as
animals they are definitely not human
which is what makes this fan art so cool
artist nan amis over at deviant art
created this super cool version of Mike
and Sulley as college kids at monsters
University though they probably wouldn't
be welcome to monsters University in
this form we love it
and we've got another favorite of my
console II that we had to share artist
Waga Shima did this side-by-side version
of Mike and Sulley and it is delightful
it's cool how similar the two pieces are
but how human the characters are on the
Left well - the horns on Sulley human
stitch we all know stitch as the lovable
troublemaker in lilo and Stitch while he
is already a pretty adorable creature
some artists wondered what he would look
like if he took on a human form the
artist known as X Li Lu chan X created
this human stitch as a blue-haired
flip-flop wearing surfer dude and we are
loving it another artist who goes by
yung 86 made this version of a human
stitch as a city kid with fire shoes and
a hoodie with ears just like the alien
creature we all love which one is your
favorite human stitch do you prefer the
surfer dude or the streetwise city kid
Bambi thumper and flour Disney's Bambi
is a beautiful story about a young deer
and his forest creature friends
it's got heartbreak triumph and an
awesome deer ice skating scene but let's
check out what these furry little
creatures would look like as humans an
artist who goes by berber art on
deviantART
did this adorable beast showing Bambi as
a sweet but slightly awkward guy with
white freckles those freckles remind us
of the spots Bambi has on his coat then
there's the lovable rabbit thumper the
artist cleverly gave thumper a drum to
thump on and finally flower the sweet
friendly skunk in the animated film we
love everything about this one Tigger
and Roo Winnie the Pooh is an animated
classic that has stood the test of time
all the adorable animals in the Hundred
Acre Wood our technically stuffed
animals come to life but we think they
still qualify for this list get ready
for your heart to melt when you see what
artist fish at deviantART drew if this
isn't the sweetest picture of Tigger and
Roo as humans we don't know what is but
another artist who goes by Marcel salic
26 took it even further and drew the
whole gang in this picture we got to say
that seems pretty spot-on the human
version of Winnie the Pooh is perfect
bolt so Lena has done it again this time
they have humanized the cuddly canine
bolt in the film bolt is a dog that
stars on a TV show as a super dog with
special powers but bolt actually
believes he has powers so when he steps
off the studio lot he is in for quite an
awakening as well as a great adventure
so Lena not only humanized bolt they
also gave mittens a human transformation
as well one fan commented that this
version of bolt looks a lot like Cameron
voice from The Descendants movies yup we
can totally see the resemblance
well done Jiminy Cricket remember the
little cricket in Pinocchio he acted as
the puppets conscience and tried to keep
him out of trouble
he tried to keep him from skipping
school and running off with the bad guys
to the land where kids were turned into
donkeys jeez what a messed-up story for
kids anyhoo everyone fell in love with
Jiminy Cricket and who wouldn't love a
well-dressed cricket tumblr user
squiggly dick thought it would be fun to
see what our little conscious cricket
would look like as a human
this dapper dude is doing a good job of
filling those
my shoes don't you think goofy and Max
we're not sure if goofy is a dog or some
other kind of animal and don't get us
started on the debate of why goofy can
walk around and talk like a person but
Pluto is a dog who walks on all fours
and can only bark that is just too
confusing but Japanese illustrator Chico
decided to really humanize goofy and his
son Max in these gorgeous drawings
suddenly we forgive Disney for the whole
weird dog thing Chico totally captures
Goofy's well goofiness and we love the
thought bubble next to max showing that
he wished he was wearing a hat without
antlers Huey Dewey and Louie chico
humanized another set of animal
characters from the Disney Vault say
hello to the human version of Huey Dewey
and Louie you might remember them as
donald duck's nephews who love to cause
trouble and make big messes
but Chico has made them a bit more well
dressed and sophisticated he depicted
them again in this drawing with Scrooge
McDuck who is also humanized these kids
look more like the little ducks we used
to see there's so much cuteness in this
picture we can't take it the kids don't
look like the ornery little rascals from
the cartoons they actually seem pretty
sweet the Muppets
now that Disney owns the Muppets we feel
they should definitely be included in
this list who wouldn't want to see what
Kermit the Frog Miss Piggy Fozzie Bear
and the rest of the gang would look like
his people we know we do artist Nick
Hoffman made this incredible piece
featuring all of our favorite Muppet
characters as humans the characters have
a realistic quality to them it almost
takes away from the lovable fuzziness
we've all come to depend on but we're
really diggin what he did with animal
Miss Piggy would be way more glamorous
if she were a human don't you think
Olaf he's last on our list and he's not
really an animal but he is a fun-loving
sidekick to ahna and elsa which is
usually the world the animals play so we
couldn't help it
we found some adorable art by artist
Lanie Kim's over at deviantART she
really captured his hopeful eyes and
sparkling personality
right and he's got a cold button on his
white shirt she definitely deserves some
warm hugs for that one
so which reimagined character was your
favorite are you as obsessed with the
Lion King characters as we were or was
Olaf more your thing let us know in the
comments and those are the 20 Disney
animals reimagined as people thanks for
watching the things see you next time
[Music]